so fine now unless you are living on the
moon you've heard about the ice bucket
challenge and yesterday my wife Amanda
Palmer took the ice bucket challenge and
she challenged
amanda is very famous for being naked
but yesterday for her ice bucket
challenge she did it in a beautiful
dress and she did it in a beautiful
dress because her stepmother
colberto fur
died
from amyotrophic lateral sclerosis a
lethal
euro degenerative disease
also known as Lou Gehrig's disease
and because it's lethal
and down here at the beach with that
to ALS dotnet slash ice bucket challenge
in case you've missed the details
the way that it works
dollars when you are challenged for
somebody tips a bucket of ice water over
your head or if you're me
you do both
so it's gonna be $100 it's gonna be a
bucket of ice water
I asked anybody watching to
donate likewise now
when I am out so I was gonna take this I
was told Neil
there is a California water shortage
it's a drought why would you do this so
we have come down to the ocean where
there is lots and lots of water we have
filled a bucket
we have filled a bucket with seawater
and ice that we bought from a gas
station please help my watch
because my lovely wife did this fully
clothed
I'm taking me Kissel
there you go thank you I would like to
challenge George ah ah Martin murderer
of characters I would like to challenge
Karen Gillan formerly the beautiful Amy
Pond okay Elizabeth Evans blasts death
do the thing
I would like to challenge Elizabeth Evan